oh hi chris kohler here with wired com
where we just got out of Microsoft's e3
2008 press conference Chris Baker what a
show it was something there was some
real head scratches some so kind of what
are they thinking moment there were a
lot of bombshells yeah and the biggest
bombshell of them all final fantasy 13
used to be sony's biggest exclusive for
the playstation 3 is now coming out
simultaneously on the xbox 360 in North
America and Europe whenever the game
finally launches they still showed the
same old pre-rendered footage of it that
they've been showing at the last like
three sony press conferences but still
huge news that xbox 360 has ff13
that was just icing on the cake they
started off showing that they've really
sewn up the hardcore gaming audience
we've got resident evil 5 which has sort
of a Gears of War co-op deal
we've got gears of war 2 which was just
looked incredible
let's do this
we've got fable two you know
sophisticated quirky RPG and fallout 3
which looks be even better than Elder
Scrolls in terms of sort of just a big
explorable game and you know lots of
lots of gory stuff what stuff hardcore
gamers love ya lots of emphasis on
online play with gears of war and fable
and even resident evil which was kind of
surprising and that was the first half
of microsoft's press conference the
second half they moved over to the
casual gamer to the wii audience they're
really trying very hard to bring those
people over to xbox 360 they've got the
new avatar system which pretty much
looks like Nintendo's little me
characters but is in fact built into the
brand new xbox live experience that they
also showed us yeah it's sort of people
talking about how Nintendo with the wii
was pursuing a blue ocean strategy they
can't compete with Microsoft and Sony
for the hardcore gamers so they're off
somewhere else now Microsoft is going
back in with a red ocean strategy they
are contesting this this area but the
other consoles of sort of own they have
direct competitors now too I toy to sing
star yeah it's a little odd because it's
like Microsoft just seems to be like
well if Nintendo has it or sony has it
we've got to have it too on the xbox 360
trivia games karaoke games things like
that and really there's also been some
very interesting announcements in terms
of video and TV content of xbox 360
including they just announced they were
partnering with Netflix and if you've
got a netflix account and an xbox live
arcade account you can watch netflix is
library of digital movies on xbox live
arcade yeah that's probably going to get
lost in the shuffle among the game press
but that could be the biggest deal
coming out of this show I mean a simple
easy to use video on demand service that
could be a really big deal Microsoft it
seems really wants to be all things to
all people they want to own the hardcore
gamers the casual gamers the movie
watchers and everybody in between
whether they can actually manage to pull
that off or whether they just sort of
end up getting stuck in the middle is
anybody's guess at this point but really
a pretty good press conference to kick
off this year's e3 time will tell
you